bonsoir claude blanchemaison on a
entendu palace qu'ailleurs qui nous
parlait des violences sur le terrain
même si on pourrait entrevoir selon elle
une accalmie en attendant pourquoi l'
escalade se poursuit-elle selon vous je
crois que l'expérience se poursuit parce
que les deux côtés du côté du
gouvernement de monsieur l'état des who
et de l'autre côté du côté du hamas
on y trouve un intérêt politique alors
du côté du hamas c'est évident que le
hamas a voulu faire payer à israël le
projet de remplacement des palestiniens
dans l'est de jérusalem par des colons
israéliens aussi a voulu faire payer
l'intervention brutale de la police sur
l'esplanade des mosquées
l'éruption dans la mosquée al aqsa qui
est un lieu sacré pour les musulmans et
que par conséquent le hamas a pris une
sorte de leadership eu dans cette
affaire et il fait aussi payer le prix à
monsieur au leader du fatah à ramallah
qui a reporté sine et d'y et les
élections qui devaient avoir lieu le 22
mai et dans lesquelles le hamas espérait
remporter s'ils ont la majorité en tous
cas un certain nombre de sièges
donc effectivement le hamas se rend bien
compte que sa position fait bouger les
les palestiniens aussi bien en
cisjordanie où ils se sont heurtés à la
police israélienne donc chez monsieur a
move mahmoud abbas est aussi un certain
nombre de villes israéliennes où il ya
une population arabe qui est là depuis
toujours
puisqu'il ya 20% les israéliens qu'ils
sont arabes et que ces villes boucher ça
ceci est très inquiétant pour pour le
gouvernement israélien
alors du côté israélien on veut en effet
éradiquer tous les éléments militaires
qui se trouvent à gaza qui pourrait
atteindre israël
on le voit bien aujourd'hui puisque
trois mille roquettes ont été tirées en
en une semaine et
l'armée israélienne a qu un objectif de
détruire tous les objectifs qui ont
quelque chose à voir avec les militaires
du hamas avec leurs organisations
politiques
alors effectivement elle a pris comme
parti comme règle opératoire de prévenir
en général une demi-heure avant le
bombardement
les personnes qui sont dans les
immeubles qui vont être bombardées et
très souvent cela ne suffit pas et puis
les dégâts collatéraux comme dans tout
les bombardements et par conséquent ce
sont les 200 morts et dans les deux sens
nord il ya évidemment des civils des
femmes et des enfants
côté israélien de finalement israël se
protège avec son système antimissiles
dôme de fer
et il y a dix morts en israël on voit
bien que c'est une guerre asymétrique et
que côté israélien monsieur netanyahou
trouvent un avantage politique puisque
actuellement il a un gouvernement
intérimaire et j'ai remplacé que des
affaires courantes
mais ce conflit lui donne un regain de
leadership politique
ce qui est intéressant pour la suite
surtout s'il ya de nouvelles élections
en israël beaucoup de pays on l'a vu un
réagissent mais peut finalement semble
avoir une marge de manoeuvre
significative qui pourrait avoir une
vraie influence modératrice sur ce
conflit je crois que le rôle d'aider des
pays arabes est important et comme l'a
dit votre journaliste le président elle
fit halte ici est à paris aujourd'hui il
se trouve qu'il est à paris parce qu'il
ya une grande conférence demain sur
l'afrique et qu'il et participera donc
il cet entretien que le président macron
pour examiner ce que l'egypte ne pouvais
faire les deux ont évidemment dit qu'il
fallait que les combats cessent
immédiatement et la france soutient la
médiation engagée par l'egypte
évidemment la jordanie j'ai aussi un
rôle important puisqu'elle est
traditionnellement protecteur des lieux
saints musulmans et on sait que la
jordanie joue un rôle dans l'est
les conversations diplomatiques ont lieu
actuellement la tunisie joue aussi un
rôle parce que elle est cette année
membre permanent non permanent du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies et
qu'elle a joué un rôle dans la rédaction
les différentes déclarations qui ont
auront été préparés mais qui n'ont pas
pu être adoptée à cause du veto
américain
trois fois de suite et puis il ya aussi
les pays qui se sont approchés d'israël
au cours des derniers mois assez souvent
sous la pression américaine sous la
pression le donald trump et qu'ils sont
embarrassés par ce que leur population
finalement prend fait et cause pour les
palestiniens et il se trouve un petit
peu embarrassé devant tenir compte de la
populaire de la delà du sentiment leur
population qui est favorable aux
palestiniens
et puis les états unis qui finalement
donc donne le là puisque c'est eux qui
protège israël et le gouvernement
netanyahou et qui font obstacle jusqu'à
présent à toute tentative il conseil de
sécurité des nations unies alors demain
il y aura une réunion en vidéoconférence
des ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union européenne
il est possible que quelque chose sorte
de la même si on rit on répète tout le
temps que les pays européens sont
divisés et en tout cas un sujet sur
lequel ils peuvent se mettre d'accord
si le sujet humanitaire car à l'évidence
évidemment la bande de gaza a besoin
d'un soutien humanitaire et d'ailleurs
ne vit comme on l'a dit dans votre sujet
également qu'un que sur sur l'aide que
lui que lui que lui que lui accordent
les agences des nations unies et aussi
l'union européenne il est possible aussi
que monsieur morel reçoivent mission de
faire une mission exploratoire pour
essayer de rapprocher les points de vue
est d'origine espagnole et espagnols ont
de bons rapports avec avec les deux
partis et tendances maison l'onu
impuissante à on l'a dit il faut dire
que washington à rejeter ce soir encore
un troisième projet de déclaration
oui alors évidemment le nu l'onu
continuera son travail conseil de
sécurité a échoué sur trois projets de
déclaration et on aura d'autres puisque
la situation conseil de sécurité c'est
que quatorze délégations peuvent
accepter les projets de déclaration qui
ont été présentés mais les états unis à
chaque fois 10 dont ceux-ci aggraverait
la situation
israël considère que ça compliquerait
les choses et par conséquent il peut pas
y avoir de projet déclarations il est
probable que cette attitude des états
unis continuera encore pendant un
certain temps jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à ce
que les images que l'on montre dans les
médias sur la situation qui prévaut
actuellement dans la dans la bande de
gaza finissent par émouvoir les
populations par émouvoir les opinions
publiques et peut-être même le congrès
des états unis et à ce moment là il y
aura une évolution de la position
américaine
mais d'ici là il ira probablement encore
pas mal de bord alors cela dit d'autres
enfin des agences de la famille des
nations unies sont très actives dans la
bande de gaza le nrw alundra qui est
l'organisation qui s'occupe précisément
des réfugiés palestiniens au proche
orient est très investi et c'est une
bonne chose que joe biden est décidé il
ya quelques semaines de verser à nouveau
la cotisation américaine et de
participer à cette agence des nations
unies dont donald trump s'était retirée
il y avait donc cette agence à ger 250
écoles et d'ailleurs on a vu que
beaucoup d'habitants ont cherché à se
réfugier dans ces écoles
pensant qu'ils étaient protégés par le
drapeau des nations unies ce qui n'est
pas absolument certain car les
bombardements encore une fois provoque
de nombreux dommages collatéraux et puis
il ya d'autres agences des nations unies
qui agissent y compris l'organisation
mondiale de la santé monsieur gebreyesus
son directeur général a dit qu'il
fallait surtout préserver les éléments
sanitaires qui existent et les hôpitaux
les dispensaires
mais évidemment la position israélienne
et que
le hamas se dissimule souvent ces
éléments militaires dans des écoles dans
des hôpitaux
derrière des des éléments civils et que
par conséquent c'est pour cette raison
que des éléments purement civiles
peuvent être bombardées donc je pense
que l'action humanitaire va devenir très
importante peut-être aussi se dirigera
ton vers la définition de couloir
humanitaire puisque la bande de gaza est
en fait totalement fermé les points de
passage habituel avec israël sont
actuellement bloqué le passage par la
voie maritime est également bloquée il
n'y a plus d'aéroport et par conséquent
c'est une zone qui est difficilement
accessible
sinon inaccessible et il faudra sans
doute prévoir des couloirs humanitaires
pour que les secours humanitaires
puissent arriver à cette population qui
est actuellement sous les bombes merci
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales